[Music]
i'm here in southeastern australia at
one of asia's first wind turbine
training centres
we're here to see what is being done to
prepare workers for a shift from jobs in
fossil fuels to those in clean energy we
need clear pathways for young people to
develop careers in the industry for
people to transition who want to join
our industry and also i guess thirdly
for people who are in the existing
industries like thermal energy where
they may well want to transition into
renewables so it gives a very very clear
pathway for people who want to join our
industry with the blade turbine
apprentices of which we're starting the
first apprenticeship in the southern
hemisphere in blade turbine
apprenticeship that will be driven by
the demand for industry so we could have
hundreds of students who are meeting the
australian demand because at the moment
with these skills you have to fly them
in from outside or send australians
overseas in order to get the appropriate
training
training centres are needed to staff
sites like this nearby wind farm owned
by axiona and ahir that has 128 turbines
producing around 192 megawatts of
electricity enough to power 110 000
homes
australia is a powerhouse for fossil
fuel exports and it's been under fire
for its slow approach to tackling
climate change that includes prime
minister scott morrison's efforts to
defend coal jobs
but despite the lack of consistent
national climate policy energy giants in
both the renewables and fossil fuel
sectors are backing programs like this
arguing it's crucial to add more skilled
workers to support the roll out of more
clean energy
[Music]